President Trump makes his closing
argument Democrats play the racism card
and we talk about Halloween costumes I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
we draw ever nearer to the midterm
elections suffice it to say right now
the house looking worse for Republicans
the Senate still looking decent for
Republicans we will break all of this
down plus President Trump makes his
closing argument but we begin today by
reminding you that if you are going to
die which means you will there's no if
really when you die you're gonna want to
make sure that your family is taken care
of and this is why you ought to have
life insurance
are you a responsible human are you
adulting are you acting like an adult
well one of the key components tacks on
like an adult is looking at
eventualities and recognizing that those
eventualities will manifest eventually
which is why they're called
eventualities this is why you need life
insurance and this is where policy
genius comes in it's the easy way to get
life insurance online in just two
minutes you can compare quotes from the
top insurers and find the best policy
for you when you compare those quotes
you save money it is indeed that simple
policy genius has helped over 4 million
people shop for insurance they've placed
over 20 billion dollars in coverage they
don't just do life insurance they also
do disability insurance and auto
insurance and home insurance if you care
about it they can cover it so if you've
been avoiding getting life insurance
because it's difficult or confusing give
policy genius a try just go to policy
genius com get your quotes apply in
minutes you can do the whole thing on
your phone right now just type it in
policy genius.com go check it out get
the life insurance ensure that your
family is taken care of in case you plot
policy genius is indeed the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance again
policy genius.com all right so as we
approach the midterm elections we're
just days away at this point republican
spirits are low in the house and high in
the senate it looks like republicans are
going to retain the senate that might
even pick up seat or to the polls from
across the country in the house are not
looking nearly as rosy for republicans
particularly in places like Pennsylvania
there are several districts in
Pennsylvania where Republicans ought to
be running well ahead they simply are
not this suggests that a lot of the
country that was Trump country is not
going to be Trump country when it comes
to this congressional election cycle and
there are a couple of reasons for that
one reason is because off your elections
typically cut against the president in
power reason number two is because
Hillary Clinton isn't on the ballot in a
pressed Democratic turnout oh there's
that as well that means that Republicans
are not going to turnout and quite as
great numbers as they turned out in 2016
and Democrats are going to turn out
maybe in greater numbers than they
turned out in 2016 that may make all the
difference while President Trump is
deciding on his closing argument
closing argument is gonna be the same as
his argument was in 2016 and that is
immigration and Democrats are not taking
the safety of the country seriously
enough now there are a lot of folks on
the Left who are saying well why doesn't
the President of the United States just
focus on the economy
why isn't he just point out that the
economy is great and if you want the
economy to keep being great then you
ought to vote for his party and the
answer is because the dirty little
secret of American politics is that
people don't actually vote based on the
economy unless there is a massive
catastrophic downturn people instead
vote on who they actually think is a
good person what policies they like in
terms of safety and security
you know economy like health care is not
really an issue that drives voters to
the polls the issues that drive voters
to the polls are the ones that trigger
the amygdala that trigger the trigger
the the fear part of your brain that the
hope part of your brain is a secondary
activation of the fear part of your
brain when it comes to politics and
president Trump knows that better than
anybody so when people say the president
Trump is engaged in the politics of fear
yes so has every other politician in the
history of mankind who has been even
remotely successful okay that is just
the way this works even Ronald Reagan a
very optimistic politician campaigned on
the basis that Jimmy Carter was wrecking
the country so you do have to have an
issue that is polarizing to drive your
voters to the polls well president Trump
has picked the caravan and immigration
this has been a constant theme with
President Trump really since 2015 2016
and folks who are moderate on
immigration libertarian and immigration
liberal on immigration they don't seem
to understand they don't seem to
understand that they play into Trump's
hands when they say there is no problem
because here's how the this game works
President Trump comes forward he says we
have a serious problem with illegal
immigration and folks say well is that
really a serious problem with illegal
immigration and he says no no it's a and
it's a serious problem and and these
folks say no there's no problem at all
everything's cool in terms there's no
it's a crisis so now you have two
choices is illegal immigration a crisis
or is it no problem at all and the
problem is for folks who say it's no
problem at all that it is somewhat of a
problem the truth is illegal immigration
is not going to destroy the country
legal immigration is not the end of the
United States elimi legal immigration is
not flooding the country with criminals
or any of this sort of thing but it is a
problem it's an economic problem it's a
cultural problem and in some cases it's
a criminal problem and if the two poles
that Americans have to choose from are
illegal
Gration is a non-problem any legal
immigration is a crisis people are
automatically going to resonate to
illegal immigration as a crisis because
they can tell that it's not a
non-problem or if you have to pick
between the two and you know it's not a
non-problem that means there's only one
option left on the ballot president
Trump knows this and the left makes a
mistake when they downplay the problems
with illegal immigration but they should
do instead is they should say yes you're
right illegal immigration is a problem
it's not a crisis here's a proposal that
we can put forward to help curb illegal
immigration while ensuring human rights
but the left doesn't want to do that
the left doesn't want to do that because
they believe that they can win this
election based on a sort of opposite
fear mongering where if you are anti
illegal immigration this means the or a
racist this means that you are a bigot
this means that you don't care about
people who are in dire need of asylum so
instead what you have is the two sides
that sort of staked out their terms
President Trump saying this whole thing
is a crisis and the left saying not only
is it not a crisis President Trump is
only fear-mongering
in order to achieve a certain desired
political result on the back of brown
people those are the two positions that
have now been staked out now is either
of those positions really reflective of
reality not really again illegal
immigration a problem is it a crisis no
it's not a crisis wait we've if it were
a crisis then how have we been dealing
with it for the past several decades and
as for the idea that it's not a problem
at all I live in the state of California
illegal immigration is a problem hey
illegal immigration is a problem for the
economy of California it's a problem for
the safety and security in the state of
California it's a problem with the
homelessness in in California but it is
a problem it is a problem that is the
actual middle ground and as I've said
for my entire career the actual solution
on the legal immigration is actually
fairly simple and everyone basically
agrees on it the actual solution is you
shut the border you make sure that
people aren't illegally immigrating you
ensure that people who would make good
Americans can legally emigrate and then
you go through on a one-to-one basis and
you see whether illegal immigrants who
are in the country people who are in the
country illegally whether those people
are of benefit or of detriment to the
United States and if they are a benefit
then they go to the back of the
immigration line and if they are
detriment to the United States they're
deported and they can't come back right
I think most people would agree on these
basic principles of immigration Democrat
and Republican but instead we've decided
to stake out opposite sides of the turf
so that we can fear monger Republicans
president Trump can claim it's a crisis
Democrats don't care about that crisis
millions will die
and then on the other side you have
folks saying well the Republicans are
evil terrible horrible racists for even
caring about this issue and obviously we
can't trust them with power so that's
how this election has broken down
president Trump has decided to make his
closing pitch the the caravan
so the caravan against you just be
straight about the caravan is this is an
annual thing every year there are
thousands of migrants who go into Mexico
from Central and Latin America and they
move up through Mexico toward the United
States border in past years they've
approached generally ports of entry
there some of them apparently have not
approached ports of entry if they go to
a port of entry and they claim asylum
well then the United States process them
processes them through normal means now
here lies a problem and there's a
problem with the United States and our
immigration system we have a policy of
catch and release which suggest that we
release a lot of folks on their own
recognizance we say okay we caught you
now we're gonna release you and you have
a court date in three months how many
people show up for the court date in
three months not all that many people
show up for the court date in three
months that's a national systemic
problem but is it an invasion our
migrants crossing the deserts in order
to break down the barrier with the
United States rush in with guns and
start shooting people no of course not
the vast majority people in this Caravan
presumably are coming to the United
States for economic opportunity not
political asylum and that is what it is
that doesn't mean we have to let them in
but it's also an exaggeration to suggest
that it's that it's a serious serious
border crisis when you're talking about
people arriving in a port of entry you
know if you need the military in order
to ensure people are not breaking into
the United States between ports of entry
that's fine but if the suggestion is
that we needed sort of a Berlin wall on
the on the southern border with regard
to with regard to all of this because we
have to shoot people who approach the
border something like I don't think
anyone suggesting that nor should
anybody suggest that in any case
President Trump who wants to portray the
caravan as a serious threat to American
security because it ties into his
broader argument that illegal
immigration must be checked and that
folks on the other side are not taking
this seriously
so here's President Trump going off on
the Caribbeans we have to have a wall of
people very highly trained people
terrific dedicated Patriots that's what
they are
you have caravans coming up that look a
lot larger than it's reported actually I
mean I'm pretty good at estimating crowd
size and I will tell
they look a lot bigger than people would
think okay well the truth is the
president unfortunately is not all that
great at estimating by his record a
number one I mean we all remember the
controversy over the inaugural crowd
sighs he routinely tweets out crowd
sizes that are not really in keeping
with the actual crowd size but in any
case the problem with the president
doing this you know just from an
objective truth point of view is that if
you stick to the facts you don't
actually have to make over-broad
inflammatory arguments you can still win
on the facts but the president
understands that people take him
seriously not literally and that means
that they take his overall point which
is that bunch of people are trying to
come into the country illegally and he's
not in favor of that and then President
Trump doubles down on another theory and
this is where again I don't like the
president's rhetoric on this I think
that when the president suggests that
George Soros is behind the caravan
without any evidence that's
conspiratorial thinking and it's and
it's not pleasant and it's unnecessary
and you shouldn't do it here's the
president doing it anyway a lot of
people say yes
now this trolls Democrats in the media
into saying well the president is crazy
on illegal immigration again the
president's game here if there's a
strategy to it then the president's game
is to as Scott Adams likes it's a sell
beyond the sale so he will say okay
George Soros is behind this and the
Democrats will say you have no evidence
George Soros is behind it and the
American public oh wait is somebody
behind the caravan maybe somebody's
behind the caravan right Trump is now
shifted the window of the conversation
the same argument can be made about the
caravan itself and the size of it when
President Trump says there are a
bajillion people in the caravan not
7,000 not 10,000 1 bajillion people and
then the media say that's not true there
aren't 1 bajillion people he said then
Americans say well but there are a lot
of people in the caravan and that's not
great so people are talking about the
caravan now right so that that is the
that is the sort of strategic if there
is some to what Trump is doing here I
think mostly it's just president from
speaking off-the-cuff and I don't think
he has to do that in order to make a
compelling argument about illegal
immigration in a second or an get to an
ad that is very controversial and you'll
see how because both sides have broke
down into their sort of partisan turf
war one side saying illegal immigration
is a massive crisis and the caravan is
just another indicator of that crisis
and the other side saying illegal
immigration is not only a crisis it's a
wonderful thing and anybody who says
differently as a racist we'll see how
that breaks down in an ad that in many
ways is sort of in the eyes of the
beholder first let's talk about
protection of your online data so let's
talk about your online security and
privacy as a public figure I am
constantly constantly worried about
being hacked or spied on I don't want my
emails compromised my credit card number
or online banking passwords stolen
something I'm not interested in how can
I protect myself how can you protect
yourself with expressvpn that's the
company I trust to defend my online
security expressvpn secures and
anonymizes your connection by encrypting
a hundred percent of your network data
hiding your IP address that means nobody
can record or access your online
activity which is exactly what you're
looking for download that expressvpn
app on your computer or smartphone then
use the internet just as you normally
would you click one button in the
expressvpn app and voila you are now
protected expressvpn is consistently
rated as the world's number-one VPN
service for Internet users so if you
want the best in online protection that
choice is expressvpn the nice post at
folks at expressvpn have extended a
special offer to my listeners right now
pricing of less than seven dollars per
month to all of my fans who go visit
expressvpn comm slash man and claim your
discount again you ought to be
protecting your data there are too many
people who are out to get it go check it
out expressvpn comm slash been right now
to learn more that's Express VP Express
VPN comm slash bet okay so all of this
debate culminates in president from
putting out an ad on his Twitter account
this ad is certainly effective it is
certainly inflammatory people have been
using the term racially-charged which is
to say it's sort of subjective as to
whether you think it is quote unquote
racist or not I'll explain why one side
is yelling racist and the other side is
saying not so much and where I come down
on that here is here's the the ad
[Music]
so it's a picture we got a mousse Baraka
Montez and he says I'm gonna break out
soon and I will kill more he killed two
cops in 2014 the Texas Democrats let him
into our country he says he doesn't
regret killing cops and says Democrats
let him stay and then there are pictures
directly of the caravan people breaking
through the borders at the Mexican
border people walking through in Mexico
toward the United States and then it
shows migrants attempting again to break
through the borders some wearing masks
because who else with Democrats let in
and then a picture again of loose
bracamontes is President Donald J Trump
and Republicans are making America safe
again it's a very inflammatory yet
obviously
inflammatory is also code for effective
okay effective ads are hard-hitting they
are memorable and they make you think
about issues that you would normally be
ignoring so a lot of folks are comparing
this to the Willie Horton ad for folks
who don't remember the Willie Horton ad
back in 1988 George HW Bush was running
against Michael Dukakis Michael Dukakis
was a soft on crime governor of the
state of Massachusetts he was in favor
of weekend furloughs for inmates so
there's one inmate whose name was
William Horton and William Horton was a
black man who was I believe in prison
for rape he on his weekend furlough went
out and raped and murdered somebody and
george w bush's allies things lee
atwater released this ad Bush and
Dukakis on crime Bush supports the death
penalty for first-degree murderers
Dukakis not only opposes the death
penalty he allowed first-degree
murderers to have weekend passes from
prison one was Willie Horton who
murdered a boy in a robbery stabbing him
19 times despite a life sentence
Horton received 10 weekend passes from
prison Horton fled kidnapped a young
couple stabbing the man and repeatedly
raping his girlfriend weekend prison
passes Dukakis on crime okay so people
went nuts in 1988 over this oh this is
racially charged okay well the way that
you read that is racially charged is if
you actually think that weekend
furloughs are not bad and if you think
that Republicans are racist by necessity
so people are using the same logic with
regard to
president Trump's ad and in just one
second we'll see how the media are
treating this so CNN actually ran a
story and the story at CNN is Trump
shocks with racist new ad days before
midterm
okay that's supposedly objective
journalism from CNN and they put that in
their analysis section he shocks with
racist and new ad days before midterms
okay and Chris Cuomo then goes on the
network and he says this is Willie
Horton redux it's obviously ugly and
it's racist as well did you see the
video the President of the United States
just released this is no Halloween spoof
what it is is a Willie Horton Redux in
fact much of the footage in this video
that we're gonna show you comes from Fox
the play started by the man who came up
with a Willie Horton ed Roger Ailes both
were grossly distorted bigoted but also
effective okay bigoted and grossly
distorted so let's talk about the
bracamontes
ad and a little bit more specificity in
order to suggest that the ad is racist
you have to suggest that the only common
nexus between the story of luis brocco
Montez and the migrant caravan is
ethnicity but basically what Trump is
doing is he's saying here's a dangerous
Hispanic man and here's a bunch of
people you don't know who are Hispanic
they must be dangerous vote for me right
that is the that is the way to interpret
president Trump's ad in a racist way
it's to say that you should be afraid of
Hispanic people President Trump will
will protect you from these evil
Hispanic people look here's a picture of
an evil Hispanic person right that's the
way to read it in the racist way there's
another way to read the ad however and
the way to read that ad is that Trump is
saying here is an illegal immigrant who
crossed the southern border illegally
multiple times he then committed a
murder on US soil of two police officers
here are a group of people we have not
vetted Democrats are saying let them
into the country without vetting you
don't know who is in that Caravan thus
you should elect me because I will
protect you from people you don't know
who may or may not end up being Luis
bracamontes and which one of those more
closely hues to the contents of the ad
well just on the objective surface I
would say the seconds it's an ad about
illegal immigration but for folks who
assume that illegal immigration number
one is not a problem at all and number
two assume that President Trump is
racist and number three assume the
president Trump's supporters are racist
well they're making the argument that
this is a racist ad now here's the
evidence that I think that this ad is
really about illegal immigration I mean
first of all it says that it is but what
what is the evidence that this is really
about illegal immigration well the the
reason that I think that is because back
in 2014 the New York Times at the
left-leaning New York Times did a
complete story on bracamontes his case
and the New York Times his story was
actually titled u.s. immigration laws
faced new scrutiny after killings right
that was the title of the New York Times
piece this is back in October of 2014 by
Jennifer Medina and Julia Preston in
other words bracamontes his case had
raised serious questions about the Obama
administration's handling of immigration
here was there was their story it would
seem to be a worst case that opponents
of the Obama administration on
immigration had long forecast an illegal
immigrant one who had been deported
twice yet returned to the country each
time is accused of killing two northern
california sheriff's officers in a
six-hour shooting rampage on friday so
here's the question is the new york
times racist they're talking about the
problems with illegal immigration and
they're linking in the problems with
illegal immigration over american
southern border with luis bracamontes
so does trump sad just because the
images that the Trump ad uses our
inflammatory and affective does not mean
that they are necessarily racist and now
here is the case that Trump is
exaggerating in the ad the case that
Trump is exaggerating in the ad because
we want to be as straight about the
facts as we possibly can is that when
Trump's ad says the Democrats allowed
bracamontes into the country and they
allowed him to stay that's an
exaggeration of the case bracamontes
entered the country illegally in the mid
in the early to mid 1990s who's deported
by the Clinton administration in 1997 he
re-entered he was then supported under
President Bush in 2001 he then
re-entered again and he remained in the
country all the way until he committed
murders despite committing ten
misdemeanor violations between 2003 and
2009 so in reality it is a bipartisan
failure of immigration policy under both
Democrat and Republican presidents that
allowed Luis bracamontes to stay in
power
or at least to stay in the country Hey
but when President Trump throws the
broader narrative again every ad is a
blunderbuss right 60-second ads are a
blunderbuss and the case that Trump is
making is I will protect you in a way
that Democrats will not protect you on
immigration and you know his policies
are harsher on immigration than
Democratic policies on immigration
there's just no question about that so
President Trump look
does he know he knows what he's doing
with the ad he is stoking the fear
centers in the brain is that completely
justified I do not think so so I think
that that the the ad is do I think it's
justified to say we're suffering from an
illegal immigration crisis again no I
don't but do I think that the ad is
racist that it's an openly racist that
it's a racial appeal I don't think that
either I don't think that either because
I actually do think that illegal
immigration is a problem regardless of
the source of that illegal immigration
so in just a second we're gonna talk
about the continuing hubbub over
Pittsburgh a kind of fascinating story
in The New York Times about
anti-semitism and all the rest of the
news of the day but first let's talk
about 1-800 flowers you never what you
never you know what never goes out of
style surprising a friend or loved one
with a bouquet from 1-800 flowers at
Cana how do I know this because I
literally just did this while I was out
of town yesterday I bought my wife every
time I go out of town I buy my wife a
bouquet of flowers from 1-800 flowers
because the flowers are just beautiful
100 flowers are perfect for any occasion
anniversaries birthdays even for making
a friend or loved ones day just for no
reason that's my favorite thing is just
to surprise my wife with flowers for no
reason at all right now when you order a
dozen multicolored roses for $29.99
1-800 flowers we'll give you another
dozen plus a base absolutely free that's
40% off the original price pretty
awesome this gorgeous bouquet of two
dozen roses and a rainbow colors is
abundantly packed with eye-catching
flowers that are sure to draw exactly
the right kind of attention roses from
1-800 flowers are packed are picked at
their peak and they are shipped
overnight to ensure freshness and
amazement they really are great and they
do last a long time to order a dozen
multi colored roses plus an extra
bouquet and vase for $29.99 go to 1-800
flowers calm / capiro order today and
save at 1-800 flowers calm / appear I
love Y 10 100 flowers and your loved one
will - 1-800 flowers calm / appear Oh go
check it out
okay so you know in all the hubbub over
president Trump and his divisive nasaw
that's kind of telling about where
Americans stand in the Trump media
divide so first of all I'd like to know
something John I'm about to say a
sentence that I have rarely said before
John Stuart is exactly correct so John
Stuart was speaking with members of the
media about the on CNN about President
Trump and how President Trump
effectively baits the media he is pretty
much correct about that
here's the comedian the left-leaning
comedian who hates president Trump
basically chiding the media for their
willingness to jump in the kiddie pool
with President Trump which is exactly
where he wants them to be okay they're
personally wounded and offended by this
man he baits them and they dive in and
what he's done well I thought is
appealed to their own narcissism to
their own ego because what he says is
these are the been the journalists stand
up and say we are noble we are honorable
how dare you sir and they take it
personally and now he's changed the
conversation to not that his policies
are silly or not working or any of those
other things it's all about the fight
he's able to to now everything else and
get people just focused on the fight
he's gonna win that fight okay and
Stuart is 100 percent right and you can
see it reflected in the polls the media
don't get it and so they're losing
there's a new political morning console
poll it's been conducted over the past
fractious violent week and what it shows
that a majority of voters think
President Trump has done more to divide
the country than United since he took
office last year but the same poll finds
that the national news media are even
worse see this is what folks failed to
recognize about President Trump it was
true when he was a candidate and is true
in his everyday politics as well
President Trump doesn't need to outrun
the public relations bear okay he
doesn't need to outrun the public
opinion polling bear he needs to outrun
you
there's a famous joke two guys in a
forest and a bear is coming after them
and one of them sits down and laces up
his running shoes and the other guys
says to him listen we're not gonna be
able to outrun that bear what the hell
are you doing guy says listen I left out
on the bear I just have to outrun you
that's President Trump
with the media right now all he has to
do is outrun the media and by contrast
he will win every race in America is
binary President Trump understands that
he understands Americans think that and
therefore he is more than happy to go to
battle with the media every day even
though the media are out there screaming
bloody murder every time he does it and
President Trump when he's in battle man
that dude has no rules that is a dude
who will bite an eye gouge that is a
dude who will crotch punch I mean there
there are no rules with President Trump
so here's what the poll shows just three
and 10 voters 30% said Trump has done
more to unite the country compared to
56% he said he's done more to divide it
fair enough but even more voters 64%
said the media have done more to divide
the country
17% say they have done more to United so
in other words when President Trump says
the media divide the country and then
the media say how dare he say this it's
so terrible he's the worst most divisive
president ever
that guy's Hitler he's the worst we
should burn him at the stake
people go okay Trump's kind of right
about you guys like you're kinda right
about Trump but he's kind of more right
about you because here's the thing
people expect something different of the
media than they expect of their
politicians and this is where Stewart is
exactly correct the media are not
supposed to have a personal stake in the
outcome of the ballgame the media are
supposed to be objective leak I mean
this is what they pitched to us was it
not now there are those of us who say we
have a personal stake in the outcome of
all these political fights I'm an
opinion journalist that means that I
give my opinion and you know where I
stand on all these issues but Jim Acosta
is not but can you distinguish Jim
Acosta's political activism from mine
except that mine is significantly more
intelligent no you can't okay Jim Acosta
is an activist masquerading as an
objective journalist and that means that
a lot of voters are saying the media are
dividing the country to majorities of
both Democrats and independents say
president Trump has done more to divide
the country 55% of Republicans say Trump
has done more to unite the country but
nobody think the national news media
have done anything to unite the country
28% of Democrats think that the media
are working to unite the country 9% of
Republicans and 14% of independents
think the media have been working to
unite the country you know why they say
that because it's true the media are not
working to unite the country and that's
why when President Trump says this stuff
people kind of not along here was
president Trump yesterday talking about
the media coverage of his fits for a
visit and the meeting went nuts over
this president Trump is correct and
everybody in America knows he's correct
by polling data after this day of unity
and togetherness I came home and sadly
turned on the news and watched as the
far-left media once again used tragedy
to sow anger
and the meter like huh no he's the one
sowing anger in division that's what he
does because he's the worst because
white men are the threats here's Don
Lemon on CNN doubling down on his white
men are the true threats in the United
States routine last night but he's
uniting the country remember the media
according to the media our great uniter
'he's nobody believes this for half a
second their analysis shows that for
every eight deadly attacks by a
right-wing wing extremists there were
one by left-wing extremists those are
the facts so people who were angered
about what I said are missing the entire
point we don't need to worry about
people who are thousands of miles away
the biggest threats are homegrown the
facts prove that okay so he doubles down
on his white men are the real threats in
America you know again Tom Lemon is not
going to talk about the murder rate in
the black community because he believes
that it would be racist to do so but
he's happy to talk about the terrorism
rate in the white community which is
significantly lower again I don't think
that it is relevant to talk about the
murder rates in any community other than
to talk about the arrest rates in those
communities but if we are going to start
grouping people together things get
really ugly really quickly and the media
know that but they don't care in Allison
cammarata on CNN she suggested yesterday
the president Trump uses the same
language as the shooter used so
therefore he must be exactly like the
shooter so he seems to be zeroing in on
the two pillars of the media continuing
his vitriolic attacks against the media
and migrants continuing to in fact
ratchet up the language about them just
and and frankly I mean I have to say it
using some of the same language that the
mass murderer at the synagogue used in
terms of invaders and invasion so whose
it so who is dividing the country well I
have said many times I don't think
President Trump is doing a good job of
uniting the country but he's certainly
uniting the country against the media
that seems like the only thing where we
all agree and the media are doing a
great job of smacking themselves in the
face with a with a club every five
seconds and you know like Sideshow Bob
with the ranks there's walking into
every rake in sight and then they
proclaim well there's no rake that's it
I haven't been hit by races they walk
around sporting a bevy of welts across
their across
peyt it's pretty incredible New York
Times is Mara gay goes on n MSNBC she
does the same thing she says that she
doesn't just blame Trump she blames
every Trump voter she's every Trump
voter is white nationalist basically I
can't disagree with that unfortunately
as sad as it is but I'm not willing to
let white voters off the hook I think
that they like the rest of us should be
treated as adults and I think that there
are a large number I would say a
majority of white Americans in this
country who are not just Democrats but
who are people of conscience or good
Americans and I believe that they need
to move from saying well I don't like
his tweets but you know the economy's
doing okay I mean they need to move from
there to reality and what's the reality
that is the reality I don't like his
tweets but the economy is doing okay
like that's true but then the idea is
that if you vote for him or any
Republican then you are part of the the
dividing of America in the destruction
of America we all have to unite by
electing who the identity politicians on
the other side of the aisle like that's
a thing yeah it's pretty pretty
incredible so it's it's a constant
source of astonishment that the media
don't recognize the whole they are
digging for themselves but they continue
to dig it deeper and deeper every single
day well in just a second I'm going to
get to Hollywood's response to to
everything and how Hollywood continues
to polarize the country and do it in the
dumbest possible way plus we'll talk
about Halloween and a fascinating study
in The New York Times about the rise in
anti-semitic attacks in the city of New
York we'll get to all of that in just a
second you're gonna have to subscribe
over at Daily wire com to get the rest
of the show $9.99 a month gets you the
rest of the show you get the rest of my
show the rest of nolza show the rest of
clavin's show you get to be part of our
daily wire backstage which we are doing
on election night and me Jeremy boring
Andrew Clavin Michael Noel's Alicia
Kraus Colton Hass is gonna make a random
appearance that's gonna be weird so
Colton is gonna get in front of the
camera and Center behind the camera
support that Bieber hair so if you want
to see all that you're gonna have to
become a subscriber and when you do then
you are also able to to ask us questions
in the mailbag you get to interact with
us all sorts of wonderful things also
when you get the annual subscription for
$99 a year you get this the very
greatest in beverage vessels check this
thing out right here now what you think
is that the beverage vessel I don't see
the beverage vessel the beverage vessel
is invisible that's what you think right
now you're wrong here's what happened I
hit a button on this how powerful the
beverage vessel is it's so powerful that
I actually I actually hit about
you are invisible right now the beverage
vessel is plainly visible to anyone but
you because you're watching cannot see
the beverage vessel because I've hit a
button on and it's just it's an
incredible incredible device that we've
created here at the Daily wire so go
check that out right now also you want
to subscribe to us over at iTunes and
YouTube and you want to leave us a
review please leave us a review over
iTunes it really does help with the
rankings also when you do that it means
you get to be part of our Sunday special
and our Sunday special this week is
awesome Tucker Carlson stopped by and it
is a fascinating conversation it is a
really really interesting conversation
so go check that out
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so let's talk a little bit
about how Hollywood is playing into all
of us again you know President Trump
understands that the nature of politics
right now is completely binary Hollywood
does not seem to understand that they
seem to believe that by clubbing
president Trump over the head and
clubbing everybody associated with
President Trump over the head if they're
helping themselves in some way and by
reading president Trump's comments in
the worst possible light that this is
somehow helping them that if they can
demonize President Trump and everything
that he stands for and demonize his
supporters as people who are okay with
all of that stuff that somehow this is
going to win them admirers right that's
sort of the logic with this immigration
ad for example so the idea is the
Democrats think that that ad is racist
they think that at is races because they
don't think you legal immigration is an
actual serious issue they think Trump is
just playing it up for racial purposes
most of the people watching that ad are
not seeing that ad as having anything to
do with race they're having they're
seeing it as having to do with illegal
immigration but Democrats by saying that
the ad is racist and then turning to a
bunch of people who see the ad
completely differently and saying if you
don't see the ad the same way that I do
ie that it's racist that means you're a
racist too you're alienating an awful
lot of folks this is why when Democrats
say things like Trump is dog whistling
to his crowd the implication is that his
dog whistling that anybody who resonates
to Trump is listening to the dog whistle
right because if he's all whistling then
who are the dogs presumably the dogs are
his supporters this is the problem with
dog whistle language if you want to say
that you believe President Trump is a
racist and you believe that people are
voting for President Trump in spite of
that racism that's one argument but
that's not actually the argument a lot
of folks on the Left are making these
days one of the arguments a lot of folks
on the Left are making is that Trump is
dog whistling to his supporters that
he's sending coded language their way
that is designed to elicit racist
responses in them so the implication is
that if you respond to Trump's illegal
immigration ad by saying yeah illegal
immigration is bad we need someone who
can protect our border that means that
you're actually a racist who's
responding to his dog whistle Samantha
bee did this routine on her awful
unfunny terrible no good very bad
non-comedic show on TBS I've said for a
while that by a mile Samantha bee is the
least funny person on planet earth it
used to be a running gun battle between
like her and Lena Dunham and Amy Schumer
and Trevor Noah and she is just I mean
the woman's Secretariat she has run out
in front she's out by lengths nobody
else is in camera view
she's just breaking away at the Kentucky
Derby so here's Samantha be doing
something supposedly related to comedy I
guess somehow talking about all of the
vague coded language vague coded
language that's being used by Trump
that's anti-semitic because I need a
lecture i Ben Shapiro needing a lecture
from Samantha bee on anti-semitism
clearly
okay let's Samantha tell me all about
anti-semitism won't you mainstream
conservatives would never say anything
negative about Jewish people outright
but there are other words they use like
coastal elites globalists Hollywood
liberals or Jon Leibowitz and currently
the biggest loudest dog-whistle it's
George Soros okay so let's go through
those for just one second so coastal
elite is not a term for jus coastal
elite is a term for Samantha bee who is
a coastal elite how do I know that
because she's a coastal elite I live on
the coasts the coastal elites when
people talk about them are typically
highfalutin Hollywood left us okay and
then she says but I can't say Hollywood
liberals cuz that is a term for June
Hollywood liberal is a term for Jew is
Samantha be Jewish I missed it
when did she convert is Oprah Jewish is
Jane Fonda Jewish like amazing I haven't
seen them at my shul any time in fact
all of the Hollywood liberals who happen
to be Jewish I've never seen in my show
because they don't go to shul because
they don't actually have anything to do
with Judaism oh there's that but it's
pretty astonishing so all of these terms
again the implication is that if anybody
uses these terms that this is somehow an
indicator that you are secretly an
anti-semite who's resonating to secret
anti-semitic messages you've taken out
your Red Ryder decoder ring and you're
sitting there and you're decoding all of
president Trump's evil messages hey so
she's used coastal elites and Hollywood
liberals those were to instead
globalists okay so the word globalist
has a relatively checkered history so
back in the 1920s and 1930s there were
anti-semites who suggested that there
was a global Zionist conspiracy and the
global Zionist conspiracy was globalist
right that was a term that was
used by anti-semites however the modern
use of the word globalists really does
not date back to the 1930s it dates back
to the 1999 WTO the World Trade
Organization riots that happened in
Seattle when people were implying that
if you were in favor of free trade this
made you a globalist that also happens
to be precisely the same sort of
terminology president Trump uses when
President Trump says globalist typically
his talking about people who are for
open immigration and open trade right
that doesn't really have anything to do
with Jews it really doesn't you know
what when when president that there was
one speech president from cave where I
thought that he used language that that
bird on the coated right when you talked
about the international bankers right
that then you start to get into dicey
territory but I'm sorry globalists is
not by necessity in in anti-semitic term
Jon Leibowitz right calling John Stewart
Chum Leibovitz no that's a way of
mocking John Stewart in fact if John
Stewart is so concerned about
anti-semitism maybe you should go back
to using his original name Jon Leibowitz
right seems to me that it's sort of
catering to anti-semitism to change her
name to Jon Stewart for scream purposes
I guess right and then she says that the
current biggest loud dog whistle is
George Soros really is David Koch it's a
dog whistle how about Sheldon Adelson
have a time steyr are all of them dog
whistles so again the implication is and
this is where the left loses it the
implication is that it's not just that
you support from because of his policies
even if you decry his rhetoric it's that
he is dog whistling to you because you
are a dog and as a dog you respond to
each and every one of his cues he feeds
you a racist Scooby Snack and then you
go out and you solve crimes right this
it's it's that's what's polite one of
the things one of the things many things
that it's polarizing the country right
now okay now let's talk a little bit
about anti-semitic attacks so there's
been a lot of talk in the in the media
about where anti-semitic attacks are
coming from and the statement by Don
Lemon is that anti-semitism is largely
coming from white supremacists across
the country as somebody who speaks on
campuses on a regular basis and I speak
with Jews a lot more frequently than
John lemon does okay then I can tell you
that Jews on campus are not feeling the
heat from white supremacists Jews on
campus are feeling the heat from
mainstream leftists and their allies in
the Muslim Student Association for
example that's where they are actually
feeling the heat and there's a
fascinating report in the New York Times
today that's actually rather telling
it's
is it safe to be Jewish in New York New
York obviously is very heavily Jewish
has over a million Jewish folks living
there just past midnight on May first a
young rabbinical student was walking
home on Eastern Parkway in Brooklyn when
he thought he was being followed a
moment after that intuition struck two
men grabbed him threw him against a car
and started punching him the victim had
dropped a box containing two hundred
bucks meant for charity the money went
untouched the student it seemed was
attacked because he was overheard
speaking Hebrew on his cell phone his
two assailants were indicted on assault
and hate crime charges no other American
city is more closely associated with
Jewish identity than New York and yet at
the same time New York has become an
increasingly unsettling place to be
Jewish the first inkling of this emerged
several days after the 2016 presidential
election when swastikas in the phrase
@go Trump showed up on playground
equipment in the Adam Yauch Park in
Brooklyn Heights but in fact
anti-semitism was already quietly on the
rise for several years now expressions
of anti-jewish sentiments have made up
the preponderance of hate crime
complaints in the city and here's here's
the interesting part okay
contrary to what are surely the
prevailing assumptions anti-semitic
incidents have constituted half of all
hate crimes in New York this year
according to the police department Jews
have been targeted we are the leaders in
hate crimes and Nobel Prizes that's
that's our thing
to put that figure in context there have
been four times as many crimes motivated
by bias against Jews 142 and all as
there have been against blacks hate
crimes against Jews outnumbered hate
crimes targeted at transgender people by
a factor of 20 a factor of 20 right this
is all stuff that the leftist that the
leftist at the New York Times are only
discovering now that Jews just got shot
those of us in the Jewish community have
known this for a little while but it was
uncomfortable for the left to talk about
anti-semitism because Jews don't rank
high enough on the intersectional
hierarchy they're not victimized enough
in the United States to be treated as
actual victims hey but here's where it
gets even more interesting if the
anti-semitism bypasses consideration as
a serious problem in New York it is to
some extent because it refuses to
conform to an easy narrative with a
single ideological enemy enemy during
the past 22 months not one person not
one caught or identified as the
aggressor in an anti-semitic hate crime
has been associated with a far-right
wing group mark Molinari commanding an
officer of the police departments hate
crimes task force told me he says I
almost wish it was sometimes more
clear-cut it's every identity targeting
every identity he says of course not
everyone is
and obviously white supremacists are
driving anti-semitic rhetoric online but
it is the varied backgrounds of people
who commit hate crimes in the city that
make combating and talking about
anti-semitism in New York much harder no
it's not that it's hard to talk about it
it's not that it's hard to talk about
it's that the New York Times doesn't
have a solid anti right wing narrative
but they can pin anti-semitism on so
they haven't been talking about hate
crimes against Jews in their own City
for years upon years and again those of
us who are who are deep friendships
inside the New York Jewish community
have known about this for years and
years and years and years it is not all
that long ago when Al Sharpton was
involved in helping to incite riots
against Orthodox Jews in Crown Heights
now he's a host on MSNBC the reason that
folks don't want to talk about
anti-semitism until a white supremacist
does it is because it doesn't fit the
narrative a lot of anti-semitic hate
crimes are committed by people who are
not right-wing or certain who are who
are not even white supremacists and are
committed by people who are openly
left-wing or are members of minority
groups and nobody on the left wants to
talk about that because it's
uncomfortable so when folks on the Left
say you know President Trump won't talk
about anti-semitism where was the New
York Times for years reporting on this I
love that they even make that I mean
it's reported in the article they say if
anti-semitism bypasses consideration as
a serious problem in New York it is to
some extent because it refuses to
conform to an easy narrative that is the
New York Times admitting to you that the
narrative was more important than the
reporting that is the New York Times
admitting to you openly that the only
thing that mattered to them was
reporting on a particular kind of people
attacking a particular kind of people I
love this sympathies are distributed
unevenly if you are extended toward
religious fundamentalists of any kind
who reached the radar of the urbane pod
save America class only when stories
appear confirming existing impressions
of backwardness the hordes of children
delivered into the world whom families
refused to vaccinate and keep
semi-literate
the anti-defamation league maintains its
own statistics and last year it reported
that nine of the twelve physical
assaults against Jews categorized as
hate crimes in New York State were
committed in Brooklyn and involved
victims were easily marked as members of
traditionally Orthodox communities so in
other words pawed save America crowd
doesn't actually care about any of the
stuff because it doesn't fit the
narrative okay and that's the reality
only when it fits the nerve is
anti-semitism a thing I want to say when
it's a Muslim shooting up
LAX at the all counter and killing a
member of my community
then it's not a big thing when it's
people being targeted for hate crimes by
folks of minority beds then it's not a
big thing when it's a white supremacist
then it's a big thing because we can
link that to Republicans and try and
proclaim that this is the big problem
across the country now again I have
never underestimated the impact of white
supremacist anti-semitism it is a
serious problem for Jews it is not the
only serious problem for Jews or even
the predominant problem for Jews in the
country when it comes to anti-semitism
okay time for a couple of things that I
like and then a thing that I hate so a
couple of things that I like I've been
doing Jewish new gunam which are sort of
prayer tunes
I guess stirred I did one for my friend
a Tomcats this is in my opinion the most
beautiful of all Jewish prayer tunes
this is from a prayer that we do on fast
days and also on Yom Kippur and also the
period between Rosh Hashanah and Yom
Kippur the parents called the Vino mark
and which literally means my father and
my king and it's it's a beautiful prayer
you know begging God for for particular
things here is a little bit of this tune
that sung in shul on all the days that I
just mentioned
[Music]
okay so what that means is our father
our King favored us and answer us but we
have no accomplishments deal with us
charitably and kindly deal with this
terribly and kindly and save us and
that's the ocean was in the save us and
save us so it's it's a beautiful tune we
sing it as I say on all of those Ephraim
mentioned days you know somebody should
actually put together a nice recording
of all the different including because
there there really are a lot of
beautiful Jewish students that nobody
knows unless you go to show so yeah
we're worth checking out some of these
things are available on YouTube to
listen to okay let's do a thing that I
hate so the thing that I hate today so
yesterday was Halloween I didn't dress
up because I didn't want to culturally
appropriate I was thinking dressing up
as Elizabeth Warren but I didn't want a
culturally appropriate or I'm just not
wide enough for that but the but there
there's a whole article every Halloween
we now have a spate of articles about
racist Halloween costumes and racist
Halloween costumes there's one in the
Atlantic saying America can't seem to
kick its racist costume habit now I
think that we ought to say that there
are certain Halloween costumes that are
racist if you are dressing up as a group
member in order to mock the group then
this would be the definition of racism
right that's what blackface is when
people you know done quote-unquote Asian
eyes and/or Tamaki Asian people that's
obviously racist but when somebody wears
a funny Mexican hat because the wearing
of funny Mexican hat and it's not
designed to mock Mexican people then I
don't think that just a white person
wearing a sombrero means that you're
moxa cat mocking Mexican people I don't
think that that's the case I I don't
think that it's the case that if you
were to dress up and and wear a kippah
because you're dressing up as me for for
Halloween there were people who dressed
up as me for Halloween I don't know why
in god's name you would do that but
there were some people who did that I
don't think that that makes you an
anti-semite because you dressed up as me
for Halloween and you put on a keep up
because I wear a kippah every day right
but there's all these talk always about
how many people are deeply worried about
Halloween costumes now again I'm not
against people being offended by
Halloween costumes that mock you but it
seems to me that people are always on
edge the number of articles about this
means that people are a lot more touchy
about it then they used to be when I was
a kid maybe that's a good thing
I think it's kind of a bad thing I think
that mostly we should be attributing to
people decent motivations I think most
of us should be saying well maybe the
guy's an idiot maybe he was just
dressing up cuz he thought the costume
was funny
not because he means to mock my
particular race sixty-five percent
according to Cato Institute sixty-five
percent of college students think they
should be able to discuss offensive
costumes without administrator
involvement though they were sharply
divided when the data were broken down
by race seventy one percent of white
students said students should be allowed
to discuss and resolve on their own
fifty six percent of Latino students
agreed forty three percent of African
American students responded in the same
way the Atlantic says if student
conversations alone could solve the
issue of fresh cop a crop offensive
costumes would not likely make headlines
every October well no I mean I think
that they would make headlines every
October because the media has an
interest in stupid topics this came up
last night in my speech and University
of British Columbia somebody asked you
know as a country we seem to be focused
on more and more minor issues and I said
right because we're wealthy and bored
and I think there's some truth to that
III think that we are wealthy and bored
and so we are willing to get upset about
nearly anything again megyn kelly just
lost her job based on a discussion of
these issues for which she apologized so
I'm I'm annoyed with with a culture that
seems determined to reinforce all of our
frailties as opposed to a culture that
takes our complaint seriously and then
also tries to think about whether we
ought to get some thicker skin okay
other things that I hate this is pretty
amazing tweed there's a guy named Scott
Hess injure this is my friend flying to
be with her family after synagogue
killings gave this note to a man on her
flight with a magda hat he read it all
okay so apparently there was a guy on
her flight was wearing a Maggie hat and
the and the note says dear sir in the
pretty red hat my name is Marissa I'm
sitting a few rows behind you I'm in Los
Angeles because my family lives here we
are Jewish we survived the Holocaust my
family members were murdered in gas
chambers all of them except the five
that live so here I am on a plane with
you as my father says we were born with
anguish I flew to Los Angeles because
eleven Jews over 55 years old were shot
and killed during prayer after they were
shot I couldn't stop crying I was afraid
I didn't want to be alone our president
blamed Saturday's killing spree on the
synagogue he said they had an armed
guard it would have been fine do you
have an armed guard where you pray God
should be safe to convene with you right
God should be safe to convene with right
a lot of people were upset angry and
scared on the plane when they saw your
hat for you on one to assume it's
politics economics in support of a
charismatic man I wonder if you mean to
scare black people Jews and immigrants
to us your hat sanctions our death our
murder our evisceration because your hat
supports a man who does little to help
us and so much to fuel hatred violence
and cruelty I love you I hope that
you're good you're good America doesn't
include flushing me and my people out
the guy was just wearing a hat and I'm
sorry ma'am this is a Wendy's wait just
because somebody's wearing a manga hat
doesn't mean that they want to kill all
the Jews
that's absurd it's absurd
but this is the the immediate
environment environment has really
created this Trump doesn't help but the
media environment has certainly created
this and the American people know it and
if Trump keeps picking fights with the
media he's gonna keep winning so long as
they continue to push this narrative
already we'll be back here tomorrow from
our home studios in Los Angeles and
we'll be doing the mailbag so now's a
good time to subscribe it's a ly
wire.com go check that out I'm Ben
Shapiro this is Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing